okay thank you for coming can everybody
hear me great so I want to talk to you
today about a problem that is actually
obvious and simple but it took us a lot
of time to get it right and that problem
is what you do when you have a machine
learning model that's actually changing
behavior in the wild and being clear
about what that means as I go as I go on
this talk so I wanted to start by saying
a little bit about stripe stripe is a
platform for doing business on the
Internet and that means the set of API
is and tools for taking payments after
doing other things like analytics and
project action this is an example of
just how much code it takes to charge
your credit card with stripe so you're a
business maybe you're selling classes
for Python or you're selling tables you
want to run credit cards it used to be
the case that you have to go to your
local bank and enrich an account do a
crazy integration parse some really
terrible XML or whatnot and now you can
just charge your cards with a few lines
of Python or a few lines of Ruby or go
if you use straight so the idea here is
that it's just very quick to onboard
your company and to start taking
payments and doing other things related
twinning your business so the machine
learning team at stripe right now has
ten people and there is no distinction
between engineers data scientists we
hire people who are primarily
statisticians by by their background you
hire people who are primarily engineers
everyone is expected to do both jobs so
no matter what your background is people
converge to this middle ground of both
building models and production icing the
code and being responsible for things
operationally so our focus has been on
fight detection for the past couple of
years and that means two things one it
means that we have to evaluate every
business that signs up for strike the
determine of that business is trying to
use stripe just to charge some credit
cards and the other thing that we do is
every time but charge comes in we have
to seamlessly score it as part of the
charging flow the determine if it's
right or not and we give this to defend
our good merchants from from fraudsters
just to give you a sense of what happens
if you use stripe or how the charging
flow works so let's say your PI data and
you are soldered restorations for this
conference online so what normally
happens is that you have a website let's
say the part of the website where you
take in customer information the name of
the person the credit card number
expiration date of the card and so forth
but one thing you want to avoid as PI
data is taking possession of credit card
numbers themselves because if you have
credit card numbers there are a number
of extra security burdens you have to
deal with if you have to make sure that
you satisfy what I call a PCI compliance
regulations which you know which mandate
how secure you are if you're ever in
possession of credit card numbers so
what happens is let's say you are
customer and you submit the registration
into PI data instead of submitting that
information to potato strippers directly
the first step is the form gets posted
to the stripe API so there's a step one
here then stripe takes that part not
card number and returns a random token
and then the customers web browser
submits that token in step three to the
potato web server and then player can
say I now want to charge this token for
$100 so the idea here is that this token
is a string that can only be charged
once and the credit card information or
anything that sensitive never actually
gets exposed to the the merchants web
server so this is how the charging
process works and from a machine
learning standpoint there are two
interesting parts here one is this first
exchange the tokenization because here
the client browser is interacting
directly with stripe so we get
information like the IP address of the
user the user agent and so forth so
there's a lot of rich information about
potential frog from this first stack
then its last up except for what we
actually charge the token we're getting
some other information like the amount
of the charge or the shipping address
and one is relevant so in building
machine learning model to catch fraud we
have to aggregate information or from
both the tokenization step
the charge stat so that's what the basis
of how we make charges any questions
about this diagram or I think I just
mentioned all right so let's say you're
taking charges a chart has been made for
a country of course registration what
are the things that can happen here the
best case scenario is that nothing
happens so the charge is made and
everything is fine another possibility
obviously is that the customer will
quote requests to refund the sort of
happens pretty normally in the course of
business the case that we want to defend
against is when the charge is charged
back or disputed so if you ever look at
your online credit card statement portal
this is what my from American Express if
you ever expand a charge there's this
link that says dispute or inquire about
this charge so if you're looking at your
statement sometimes you may notice
something that is not a charge that
you've made you can charge it back or
dispute it and tell them that can
express or chase or whoever that you
think this is fraudulent so what we're
trying to do is we're trying to detect
events to where the authorized
cardholder did not make the charge
because those end up being charged back
were disputed and that means that the
merchant loses the funds for that charge
and also gets penalized a fifteen dollar
fee so the TLDR here is that charge
backs are bad and we want to detect
unauthorized uses of cards before they
happen one thing that's hard about this
is that credit card statements close
once a month so it often takes several
months before someone notices and
reports fraud so it's the case that a
charge may today may only get reported
as fraudulent to stripe in two or three
months there's a very very distinct
delay here but just to sort of set the
framework open to talk about we're
trying to detect and stop fraudulent
transactions so let's say it's the end
of 2013 and this is actually
approximately true for the stripe time
line it's the end of 2013 and there has
been no Fida tection today so for all
history up until the end of the year we
were just letting fraud through and that
isn't quite true but let's say it's
let's say it was but let me fly through
prefer getting charged back and we
decide we have to build a machine
learning model to detect and stop fraud
so when they pulled a binary classifier
that says for every charge that comes in
this is the probability that it will
eventually get charged back or disputed
and there are a bunch of features that
can go in here like the client IP
country the card in which the country
was issued the recent history of the IP
address and the card number but the
important part here is that were ability
and binary classifier to detect fraud so
let's say we train it on data from
January 1st to September 30th so we have
nine months of data to train it on and
then we validated on data from October
and we're skipping November and December
data because of this two month lag and
getting the labels we want to wait at
least 60 days before we know that a
charge will get charged back or not
so we build a model and we look at the
positioner we call curves and the ROC
curve and they all look fairly good does
everyone familiar with the term its
precision and recall right so precision
is of the charges that the model thinks
are fraud what fraction are actually
fraud and recall is of all the Chartists
that are fraud in the world what
fraction do we catch so if you look at
this this top graph this is saying that
at some threshold I'm looking at the top
right here just a precision of
approximately 0.8 and it recalled
approximately or 0.7 still we're
catching 70% of all fraud and 80% of the
things that we flag are actually falling
it's a question back there what I'm
talking about right now is all the
transactions right so every time a
charge comes in every single one we
score independently and block not
depending on its score all right so you
know we have the ROC curve you have the
position recall curve they look fine and
we decide to action this model by saying
we're gonna block a charge if the score
is about 50 and we've made some
positioner we called head off that we
like so you put this into production
beginning 14 and we start blocking
charges based on the model scores so the
first question that arises is you know
we train this model on data ending in
September we evaluated on data from
October and now it's January so how well
is the model doing or a more precise
question is what are their production
precision recall so what fraction of
charges being blocked in production are
actually a fraudulent and what fraction
of all fraud are we catching with this
model so that's one question and let's
say let's say in January or February a
particular business complains to us and
says we're getting lots of reports that
you are blocking charges there actually
aren't fraud so the false positive rate
is higher than we'd like so maybe we'll
consider something like raising the
policy here to block only the scores
above 70 so we're a little less
stringent so both of these questions
have something in common which is that
they're hard to answer so I'm gonna have
idea of why these are difficult to
answer right so we're blocking charges
and when we block them we can't observe
the outcome right we care about charter
sort they're gonna get disputed what if
we block these thousand charges we don't
know what will happen to them the chart
has never happened so we can't observe
the labels right so for policy
evaluation and for model evaluation
because we're not able to observe the
outcomes that we're trying to prevent we
actually can't very easily answer these
questions so we'll get back to this
shortly so you're here's another issue
hopefully it's the end of the year it's
the some 31st 2014 the model is been
running a production for a full year
now we decide all right it's been a year
it's time to retrain the model one so we
do exactly the same thing we had a year
earlier we trained on data from January
1st to September 30th and then we
validate on data from October 1st to
October 31st so again remember here that
we're building a model on charges and
the target for the binary classifier is
was the charge disputed or not was the
charge reported as fraud by the
cardholder
so we train on more recent data we sort
of have the exact same parameters and
let's even say that the model features
are about the same
so we then look at the validation data
again from October of the more recent
year and it looks substantially worse
than it did a year earlier right so the
playing 13800 we had an ROC our AUC of
something like point nine three now it's
dropped to 0.7 oh so not nearly as good
as we thought it was gonna be or that it
was previously so let's say all right
we'll just give it a shot anyway and we
test in a production by seeing with a
little block and the results are just
terrible we say okay because this new
model or block these thousand charges we
take a human to inspect the manual
waiting they didn't look like fraud and
maybe we got a lot of reports from
businesses that say are saying you're
blocking way too many good charges now
so the methodology was the same all of
the parameters were the same nothing
changed about how we built the model
except that we move this window for
training and validation a year in the
future so why are things so much worse
now that's right so I got some obviously
for 2014 we were already blocking a lot
of fraud right so all this fraud that we
would have seen we never got to observe
so now we're feeding into this model all
these transactions and all the ones that
are fought are the ones that were not
caught by the model already running so
what's happening here is we're not
training a model on all our fraud we're
training one on the residual or on the
fraud that wasn't caught
the previous model and what's
interesting about that is we're
essentially training a model on the
hardest fraud or the stuff that we can
catch before so it's not surprising that
performance is pretty pretty bad
compared to the original model all right
so what could we do about this we could
in theory you run both mullahs in
parallel we could say let's run that
model for 13 and then you multiply K 14
at the same time so that way we're
catching the base fraud and we're also
catching the new harder residual fraud
with a newer model and but we still have
the problem with that of how do we about
this combination like we can't estimate
precision and recall because we don't
have the labels in general so even if we
try something like running this ensemble
in parallel we really have no good way
to say how well this combinational model
is doing so all these problems or all
these questions have the same underlying
problem we're making intervention we
can't evaluate the labels so we can't do
mod evaluation we can't do policy
evaluation and we can't retrain the
model in an unbiased way let's just
saying write it when it said no so what
we want in all these cases is an
estimate of the distribution that would
exist if there were no blocking or no
intervention in production right to be
able to say here's the precision here's
their recall to be able to train a new
model and we want an example we want an
estimate of the charge stream that would
exist if we weren't blocking we want to
say here are the charges near the label
so that would that would be in the world
if there were no model that were
changing behavior so how can we how can
we do that
right so the first iteration is to
saying why don't we just sample from the
Charter through your ordinarily blog so
let's say if our policy is block if it
scores about 50 we'll normally do that
but let's say for 5 percent of charges
we'll just allow them to go through
right so we're not going to block
everything well block mostly everything
but we'll have this holdout set in
production to see what happens to them
so it's pretty easy to compute the
precision of your model if you do this
for the 5 percent of charges that you
left through you just ask what fraction
of them end up getting disputed and
that's your position so what about
recall so we're gonna let through 5
percent of the charges that we think are
fraud how do we estimate the total
number of charges or the total fraction
or fraud that we're catching so let's do
that calculation so let's say that there
are a million charges and 900,000 of
them have a score below 50 so the model
says they're fine they're not fraud
let's not do anything about them and a
hundred thousand of them have a score
above 15 which the model would
ordinarily block
so first for those with a score below 15
we got to observe the outcomes because
we don't block them so let's say eight
hundred ninety thousand of them end up
being fine and ten thousand of them are
blocked or sorry are disputed as
fraudulent so we got observe the
outcomes for all the charges as they're
below the score threshold now for the
ones above the threshold we're only
letting 5% of them through so for the
other than 5% we block the you know we
block them and we can never observe the
outcome so that's this bottom row here
so for the five thousand that we left
through let's say that a thousand of
them are not fraud
ie they were never disputed or charged
back and four thousand were so in total
we've seen fourteen thousand chargeback
events that actually is in the content
of fraud the total amount of fraud that
we caught is four thousand
times 20 because you can imagine we're
only letting through 1 out of every 20
cases that we would have blocked so for
the 4,000 examples are fraud to be
observed
there are 19 other example is that we
did not observe because they were
blocked so we scale the the amount of
caught fraud by this factor of 1 over
0.05 so there are 80,000 cases of quote
caught fraud
10,000 of uncaught fraud so the recall
is 80,000 over 90,000 or 89 percent -
any questions about this computation all
right so we're letting through 5 percent
of charges and we can compute precision
and recall directly by by doing this
estimate so what about training suppose
as before we're only gonna train on
sample that's where we have the label
where we've observed the outcome but now
we'll do is for charters that would have
been blocked or we left through this 5%
holdout we're gonna weight them by a
factor of 20 again for the same reason
that for every charge that we would have
blocked but that we left through it
ended up getting disputed and there were
actually in quotation marks plenty of
such samples in the unconditional
distribution if we hadn't been blocking
at all
so we're training around a force here
for example and we pass in sample
weights and the weights are one for the
samples of that or the hardness that we
would have blocked and we weight the
ones that we would have left through by
20 and the ones that we did block and
never observe the alchemist before we
just forget about completely so we're
only training if we can observe the
outcome and we weight the outcomes or
the samples by 1 over the probability
that we allowed it to pass through a
production any questions about this yeah
back there
so for the you're saying for this last
row here so you're saying we'll just
block everything that we think is fraud
and if they are misclassified will they
let people tell us that so it is
actually the case now that there are
methods and the stripe API and the
dashboard for a lot of businesses to
tell us if they think something is fraud
or not it just turns out to be the case
that these tools aren't used as much as
that you would think right and there's
Stephanie a bias for a pulp for
reporting false positives or false
negatives because merchants or
businesses can always tell by human
inspection if something is fraud or not
right so it's true that if something was
a false positive maybe it'll get
reported by the business but if
something was a false negative they'll
often goes from undetected so like
asking for human reports that does add
value but it's not as signals we can get
by seeing what does happen eventually
does that make sense okay so we have
this data set now where some samples are
waiting and we use the weights both in
our model evaluation sorry number or
anything then you can pass the weight
correctly and so a lot of cycle urn
classifiers as we do here for the venom
Forest regressor you want to do the same
thing in validation so when you're
computing your ROC curve you're doing
whatever you do for cross validation you
want to include the weights there as
well right because we have to pretend as
if every charge that would have been
blocked that was left through there were
actually 20 such charges
I mean want to include that estimate and
the training and the validation so where
we are right now is we are saying
if the scores below 50 and then we allow
the charge to go through no matter what
and if the score is above 50 we all
block it with probability point nine
five I don't let it go through
probability point zero five so we have
the step function here which tell us
you'll be doing write it the probability
that we allow the charge is constantly
one for scores below fifteen and it's
constantly point zero five for scores
above fifty so can anyone think of why
this set up might not be ideal that's
right so we have to remember that
there's a business cost to doing this if
the transaction has a score of 75 I mean
let it through then it could get charged
back and then the customer has to eat
the cost of this dispute and the fee and
all of that so we're doing this
evaluation and we're doing it because we
want them all to get better but there's
a real cost to doing it right we're
actually allowing more fraud to happen
to me what if we just said block
everything of the scores about 50 so
let's imagine now that as a business
policy we say something like we're
willing to only let through an
additional let's say thousand disputes
or chargebacks per month so we actually
now have a budget for doing this
evaluation we're a lot of let's some
things through so we can observe the
outcomes and about our models but we're
only willing to incur a thousand extra
chargebacks per month so would our
policy about what we love to do change
right now we're letting through five
percent of anything above a score of 50
if you want to maximally or optimally
use our budget for model evaluation how
would this policy change yeah we can
have a smoother curve so one thing about
this is like if the charge has a score
of a hundred it's much more likely to be
fraud and if as hard as a score of 50
right if our classifier is any good so
the area in which there's the most
uncertainty is right around the
threshold of 50 right there it's much
more likely that we're making mistakes
for scores to have first hard to have a
score of 51 than it is we're making
mistakes the first charge that have a
score of a hundred right if it's 50 it's
50/50 that the chart is fraudulent if
the score is a hundred it's almost
certainly fraud so if we're only gonna
let through a certain number of charges
per month as part of this mod evaluation
budget we want to selectively let
through charges in the area we're most
uncertain and that means right around
the threshold of 50 so instead of a step
function we can have something that
smoother and this is definitely a way to
give you an example of the idea so what
we want here is a function that map's
the classifier score to what you might
call a propensity score and the
propensity score is the probability that
we allow the charge to go through and
what we want is that the score is the
propensity score is pretty high if the
classifier is score is saying the 50 so
there's a lot of uncertainty we want the
propensity score to be low and for
charges that we're pretty confident or
fraud so we're getting more information
in the regime where there's the most
uncertainty any questions about let this
head up yeah
so the question is we're learning more
around a score of 50 but there is more
cost the customer right so one thing
that this graph does not do but which I
should have said is that you want to
imagine that the area under these two
curves is the same so we're not actually
just we're not letting through more
we're just moving the weight from the
top end to the bottom end or what I'm
saying what I mean is that there used to
be uniform distribution between fifty
and a hundred left through what we
actually want is to let through far more
at fifteen and a lot through far less at
a hundred so the total amount that the
total number of cars is letting through
is the same we're just doing the
roulette more letting more through for
the lower scoring charges that's
actually fine because more of the
charges there the harder that have score
of say fifty five are much more likely
to be false polishes and there's no
charge that have score of 100 right so
where we're letting a few charges that
are more likely to be not fraud as part
of this change in policy yeah so two
questions one question is what if the
distribution of scores like I guess for
these multi production and the score mr.
Bhushan is very bimodal so over 99% of
scores are saved between zero and one
100 point scale and you'll have what
looks like a very exponential passed
that and then another blip at around 100
okay so it's something like that
something like that
and then the second question was why
don't we experiment for lower thresholds
is that what the question what
ah so that's a great question so why is
it only smooth on one side and on the
other side right why is this a
transition where it's constantly one
until it hits 50 and then we start
dropping off there that's right because
for scores below 50 we already got to
observe the outcome and let's say we've
decided based on the positional recall
the trade-off that 50 is the right
number so if something has a score of 40
we can observe the outcome anyway and we
gain no information by a reversing
something that we would let through and
blocking it that's just a way to
introduce false an additional false
positive is that your question okay all
right so we have this smooth sumo now
right question the back
that's right that's a good point so
everything that I'm doing right now I'm
talking about charge counts but it's all
generalizable and in reality we do this
both for account and for volume right so
you actually depending on the nature of
the business
sometimes counts matter more sometimes
volume matters more and we have models
for both things by dollar volume and
just by count yeah right here oh how do
you mean by it's key to house fire so
yes we're letting through way more
things that have a score 51 and have a
score of 100
so if you rebuild a mortise based on
what gets left through then charge with
a score of 51 do get or too much weight
in the model so we'll address this in
the in the next few slides okay so this
is a view incur the idea what's
happening here the charge comes in we
have a classifier score we pass a
classifier score into this propensity
function which is sort of half signal
and that you see here and and then we
say all right well the original action
is just determined by comparing the
score to 50 and then the action we will
take we just say pick a random number
and if that number is less the
propensity score then we allow the
transaction to go through if not then we
bought the transaction and every time we
do this we want to record a few things
it's going to record the charge ID we're
going to record the classifier score or
we want to record the propensity score
and then both the original action ie
they actually have taken just based on
the classifier and the selected action
the action that we would take based on
this propensity function
so let's say here's an example of a
sequence of charges so what happens here
for charge 1 it has a score of 10 that
maps to this flat region in this
propensity function here so probably the
real doubt is one point the original
action is to allow it
the chosen action is to allow it we
could observe the outcome the charges
okay let's say for the second charge it
has a score of 45 again that's below 50
it's the probability that we allow it is
a 1 we do allow it we chew so loud and
we can observe the outcome and it's
fraud so charge 3 has a score of 55 that
corresponds to about the probability of
0.3 that I'll be allowing so now we're
in this smooth for being part of the
propensity function we end up block it
you know the original action because the
score is about 50 is to block it and we
do end up blocking it based on this
comparison of the propensity score to
the random number and there's no outcome
to be observed for a charge for has a
score of 65 the probability they'll be
allowed as point to we would choose to
block it because the score is above 50
but based on this random comparison we
allow it and we can observe the outcome
which is fraud there's a couple more
examples score of a hundred and people
if they be allowed is very small we
would block it in the ordinary world
random actions also block it so we can
observe the outcome and finally let's
say that there's a chart of a score of
16 I believe it'll be allowed is 0.25
we would ordinarily block it but we
randomly choose to allowed in this case
and we observe the outcome and it's okay
so we as we're doing the production we
have a log line for every action and
each log line looks like this like a row
in this table and and then we can take
this table and do some analysis with it
so for example well first you know we
only want to consider charges that we're
allowed right because if we block a
charge then we can observe the outcome
and then what do we do for the charges
that we do allow
sort of per your question earlier we
don't just include them with a uniform
weight in the evaluation and training
data set what we want to do is we want
to weight each charged by one over the
probability the probability that we
allow it so you'd imagine that if we
allow each heart the probability point
one and we see that it becomes a dispute
then there were ten charges in total
nine of which we didn't allow that were
not observed but would have likely been
disputed so for every charge or
previously we were waiting by this 220
because we were letting every charge to
the same probability and now average
charge has a different ability of being
left through and want to weight by 1
over that probability and evaluation and
training so some examples so I filled
out all of the charges that were not
read in observing outcome so we only got
to observe an outcome for four charges
one two four and six so I've also added
a column here for the weight where the
weight is one over probability that we
allow right so if we allow our mobility
point two the weight is five if we allow
probability 0.25 the weight is four so
we have this table now I'm let's say I
ask what are the precision and recall of
the policy when we block charges if the
score is above 50 we got to observe
these four charges and the question is
what are the model of precision and
recall based on the protection data if
we're blocking charges with a score
above 50 so let's do precision first
there are two charges and count that
have a score above fifty four and six
but we can't just count them we have to
include their weights because charge for
is actually one of five similar charges
we just get to observe the other four
and some weight for charge six we
actually want to think of this as there
are nine charges with a score above
fifty and of those nine
I've were fraudulent right so the
position is 5/9
and then for recall so there are two
charges here and count with the rajala
numbers to number four but when you wait
them there are six by wait and five out
of six of them have a score about fifty
so the recall is five over six or 0.8
three the questions about this
calculation let's do one other one so
the exact same table let's say now we
wanted to figure out what if we change
our policy to block only if the score is
above 40 what's the position of that
well now there are three charges an
account with a score above 40 but there
are ten in weight right number two for
insects have a twelve one five and four
and of those six out of ten in weight
we're actually fraud so the decision is
0.6 and for recall there were six
charges in weight that were fraud and
all of them had a score above forty
so the recall is one just the idea here
is that for every charge you got through
you pretend that it has one over
political you allow the charge sample is
in the underlying data set and you do
all your evaluation and model training
based on those weights I'm going to skip
the other equation it's the exact same
thing so this function that we have like
this step function that turns into the
Sigma weighting it controls what you
might call the exploration exploitation
payoff there's actually a banded problem
right so the the more you let through
the more data you get to train future
models and the more data you get to buy
with the current model and what the less
you are exploiting the benefit of your
current modeling like the less you are
catching and blocking fraud similarly
the steeper that sigmoid is the more
fogger catching but you're giving
yourself
opportunity to explore new possible
models and do model evaluation so all
these things that were computing the
very the precision the recall these are
all estimates because we're estimating
the distribution that exists without the
model blogging and the more that we left
through the less the variance we
introduced for these estimates and one
thing that you definitely want to do is
you actually want to bootstrap these
computations so what we do here is if
you had enough data we would continually
sample from this table uniformly at
random from the rows do this computation
again and then we get error bars on the
position in the recall and it's all this
whole methodology comes from a paper on
search evaluate or search for search
result ranking we're didn't buy a few
people at Microsoft in facebook so I
recommend reading this paper listed here
for more detailed information
it's one of finished up with a couple of
technical issues so there's actually a
pretty clear security or security is the
wrong word but uh there's a a pretty bad
weakness in what I've described here in
terms of defending businesses against
fraud so any idea what that might be
well that's definitely true but we know
that you know we're doing that so if you
go up right for scrolling back all the
way here and add a hundred and that red
line isn't it zero let's say it's at
point zero zero one so what that means
is that if you're a fraud sir and you
catch on to this you know that if you
just try the same card a hundred times
there's a good chance it'll go through
right so you can just essentially you
take whatever you were doing and
multiply it by a hundred and now you're
almost guaranteed that's something we'll
eventually get through and you can
observe the outcome if you're testing
the card or actually go buy the thing so
what you actually want to do is you want
to use something like
you don't make a random coin flip for
every charge you compare your propensity
score to something like a hash of the
card number and in today's date and what
that means is that for any given card
either all the charges will not get
reversed and there's no possibility of
the person continuing to try the same
color of an over again or that if you
get reverse and get observe the outcome
so the idea here is that you want to
group these events into let's say
attempts by card and not just being
totally independent from try to try and
last more puzzle is let's say we compute
position or recall or using this
estimator is over rolling windows so I'm
going to estimate the position of recall
of my model over the past two months
every day what we observed initially is
something like this where there are
dramatic swings and the values of the
position that we call estimated by the
system so any idea is why we might
observe this behavior yeah back there
we're not so all we have is like fixed
policy block of it scores about 50 we've
got with a position to recall out
subscribed above and they they tend to
be constant for a while and then they
swing wildly after every now and then
other things like dramatic phase
transitions
yeah but not there
that's exactly right so what happens
here is that if you are waiting as such
that there are events with incredibly
high weights let's say you have a
propensity score of point zero zero zero
zero one and that results in a charge of
weight let's say ten thousand then one
charge a very high weight heading
through if you classify correctly will
result in a huge improvement to your
model where do you classify it
incorrectly always Alden a huge hit to
the mall of Mets and level metrics so
what you want to make sure that you do
in this case is that you never have
weights that are too low right because
single highway events can have a
dramatic impact on your estimators and
that's it
sure
that's probably true but this this
behavior is observed sort of not just
seasonally you know this particular but
comparing erratic behavior is not result
of Christmas it's a result of these
highway charges right so if you have a
single charge that has let's go back to
this let's say let's say a charge six
here had a weight of like a hundred
thousand right then that charge would
dominate the precision of the recall
calculation so if we got charged six
correct ie
it was fraudulent then our position our
recall would be very very high just
based on this one charge what if we got
charged six incorrectly that a way to
say ten thousand their position to
recall it be really low right so if you
have any charges that have a high weight
like what's happening here is we write
we have a rolling window and we roll on
to the period that has a charge of high
weight and we obviously misclassified it
metrics went way down and it went
everything looks would look play bagging
and then after a couple of days there
was another highway to vend week I cited
correctly and then the metrics all went
back up again
so you have to correct for sort of high
weight instances we have to make sure
that you know you're seeing what really
is moving that this doesn't happen
yes exactly
well go down to zero then you actually
will have a right you want to you want
to go back down to something that's
banded away from the zero let's say like
0.02 and I'll be the max weight is 50
yeah
let's write another time now so risk in
conclusion you know even a/b test models
in reality here by doing this
methodology you can evaluate infinitely
many model variants offline just buys
from having these log lines and doing
the weighting and you sort of have most
flexibility they are from model
evaluation and Muller training
flying this is work done by three of my
colleagues Ryan Wang rotten Kramer and
was fretting and for shameless plug here
we are very very hiring a the scientists
and engineers permission
4ml so if you know anyone please refer
them and that's it thank you